do you have a list of people who you are  dying to work with um yeah for sure who  is at the top of this list Oh God of  course now I don't spaced out on me this  current wave of comedians I think are  particularly are we talking about  Kristen Wiig or something yeah she's  amazing  that's a comedy and you're Schumer is  amazing Amy she can you want to do  comedy I would love to do a comedy I  just I I they're exciting me more than  anybody else real sure right now  final question okay all right louis c.k  Amy Schumer come to you yes with a roll  yes but it requires nudity will you do  it oh wow see this is why you are paid  the big bucks is a really good question  I say you do it I would do it you would  yeah I know totally gratuitous nudity  yeah I'm gonna get it there's no reason  for it yeah